hello conan o'brien here all last week i
used my
morsel of television to hear black
voices
as we struggle with this intense period
of racial anguish
and upheaval i'd like to continue that
tonight
earlier today i spoke with the mayor of
saint paul minnesota
mayor melvin carter he is at the
epicenter
of this national crisis and he has a
unique perspective
so without any delay let's get started
while george floyd may be the most
notable
african-american to have died at the
hands of minnesota police he was not the
first
in 2018 tonight's guest was elected the
first
african-american mayor of saint paul
minnesota
two years after the philando castile
shooting in the neighboring
suburb of saint anthony he's a fourth
generation resident of saint paul
and the son of a former saint paul
police officer i'm very honored to
welcome
mayor melvin carter mayor thank you for
being here i know you're busy this means
a lot to us thank you
thank you for having me on i appreciate
it you know
um we'll start uh let me just
ask you personally how you're doing you
your family everyone
everyone doing okay during these insane
times
you know that's a super loaded question
these days and i think some of it
depends on
uh what you mean and some of it depends
on what the day is uh we're we have a
pretty big family
uh we've got uh a crew of children uh in
and out of the house who are you know
been trying to
socially distance learn you know social
distance learning at home right
right and that's been fun as fun as it
has been for everybody else
uh we've got a three-month-old at home
yeah i want to talk about that you have
a
three-month-old so in the midst of this
incredible turmoil not just kovid but
uh all of the uh unrest and and
anguish of the past week and a half you
have a three-month-old
that's right and um so i just want to
say you're welcome to come stay with me
yeah right i appreciate that she um
try as i might she doesn't have the
proper appreciation yet for the term
mayor
i try to convince her that like one day
one day this will mean a lot to you so
like
let me get some sleep but no it doesn't
work you're not getting the respect
you should uh well let me start because
you uh one of the reasons i i really
wanted to talk to you and i again i am
so appreciative that you could make the
time for us
is that you're kind of because
you're the mayor uh of saint paul and
also
the uh the son of a police officer uh
and you were at the nexus of so many uh
you know points right now you are right
uh
and your point of view i think is
incredibly valuable obviously and so
i wanted to start by talking to you i
mentioned it up front the philando
castile
shooting several years ago
which was another horrific incident
which was caught on video
witnessed by a lot of people you had a
personal
connection uh to that incident i know it
happened
uh in a neighboring jurisdiction just
outside st
paul that's right you knew philando
castile is that true
not well i would see him around
community he graduated from
my same high school uh a a year away
from my younger sister year ahead of my
younger sister
the school he worked at was the school
that my children went to kindergarten in
uh and so he was around community i
would see him at the coffee shop and i'd
see him around community a bit
but didn't know him well but of course
it's uh really traumatic for our entire
community for something like that to
play out
and while the rest of the world was kind
of battling with this major
kind of socio-political thing we were
locally explaining to our children what
happened to mr phil so it was
traumatic on a bunch of levels right
right it was uh
a person in your community that you knew
and that's right
and and and and now that event obviously
very
traumatic and and got a lot of attention
but george floyd seems to obviously
has blown this wide open and
uh and and been a just an incredibly
wrenching moment
yeah for a lot of americans probably
um exposing a lot of us to a reality
that
that we were not aware of but you grew
up
in this reality you grew up your father
your father uh was on the police force
but also
you had i'm guessing
uh interactions of your own with maybe
being pulled over
or treated differently because of the
color of your skin
yeah with without a doubt you know so
the video of george
i mean unfortunately we've had this
conversation for
years now uh which is like how bad does
a video have to be
you know how egregious does it have to
be how obvious does it have to be
uh for us to say okay wait that's enough
somebody's got to be held accountable
for this
and we said that after final castile was
killed and like okay
this clearly like for it to be this
obvious it's clearly somebody has to be
held accountable
and then we saw that officer acquitted
and so it seems that with each
video it keeps sort of testing the
limits of
just how much that somebody can get away
with
with regard to taking a black life or a
brown life
yes i've had lots of experiences you
know frankly good and bad right
um i have the privilege it's a level of
privilege to grow up with my dad being a
police officer
because so i had this my first car was
in 1984 two-tone gray
a monte carlo right it was very sweet in
a way that like only 17 year old boys
can like truly appreciate
yes right and so i get pulled over all
the time right and when that when i got
pulled over
they'd run my plates and run to my
father who was in internal affairs at
the time
uh and i would get you know let go with
like a a
a warning right and but but you're right
like you know part of my
part of my truth is you shouldn't have
to be a police officer's son you
shouldn't have to be
a college student or a a city council
member or somebody special
to be treated with with basic dignity i
think van jones said it really well in
your conversation with him is that like
the the the the trauma of the violence
of that george floyd video is that
it cracks all of the remaining solace
that we take in those conversations that
we have with our children about
if you just behave if you just like do
everything that they say
if you just don't resist uh then you
know you'll be able to kind of walk out
of that conversation safely
he did all those things now i'd say the
maybe the most heartbreaking part about
that video
is the paradox that he didn't even like
fight to try to breathe for his
to try to fight and to struggle for his
last breath
but like we all know that if he had uh
that struggle
would have been used as the excuse uh to
cover up
the fact that he was killed in the way
that he was
now we're at this uh national moment
today very much the conversation
the conversation over the weekend uh
and and last night many demonstrations
have been about
the police and um
i'm sure you have very strong opinions
there's people out there that
uh there's a big movement to defund the
police
yeah and i would imagine that like many
things
that that's it's complicated it's
probably a very complicated
question uh when you hear about
defunding the police or many people
including myself who don't really know
what that means
sure sure i'll tell you what's what what
i think is not complicated
is the fact that we've bought into this
notion
this myth uh that public safety is just
as simple as
uh police prisons and prosecutors right
and every time we feel uncomfortable
or every time we feel unsafe as a nation
uh we can find billions of dollars to
double down
on police prisons and prosecutors uh yet
it hasn't worked we still don't feel
safe you know uh and one of the truths i
think we have to grapple with is the
reason we don't all feel safe
conan is because that public safety
framework that that that model
really isn't designed to make us all
feel safe it's designed to like draw a
circle
and protect or insulate the people
inside the circle from the people
outside the circle at all costs
it creates a level of resentment from
the people who
feel like they're outside of the circle
it definitely creates a level of
a feeling of being threatened by the
people inside the circle because
it's clearly a tenuous balance and then
we drop our police officers right in
this epicenter of all of that
uh in a way uh that you know community
members are gonna look at them
as you know you're the force that's kind
of here to keep me out of the greater
prosperity of
kind of the broader community and so as
we talk to our police officers and we
hear them say all the time
we don't have the capacity or the
expertise to be you know the social
workers the mental health counselors or
the grief counselors
or the drug counselors or you know all
of those different things that we all
know
would help in community and so you know
one thing i think is very clear is
uh you know if if we just approach
public safety with like this police only
perspective
that we have for so long to me that's
like approaching public health with an
ambulance only perspective right like we
know how ridiculous that will be to just
chase problems after it happens
we have to start investing in families
and in neighborhoods uh to try to reduce
the likelihood that something bad is
going to happen
in the first place so it starts with it
we hear our police officers saying
we can't be the mental health counselors
and the social workers and the drug
counselors
all of those things are they're taking
orders like those are things that we're
clearly identifying a need for
so we ought to invest in those things
we know we know conan i'm guessing you
live in a safe neighborhood right
i do yeah and i would guess that in your
neighborhood
uh you have strong schools i would guess
that folks have access to really good
jobs
i would guess that you know folks have
the ability to kind of make their money
work for them and kind of just
and live a quality life and so if we're
just
um investing money to hire people to
chase problems after they happen
then that's the opposite of investing to
transform our transform
our most challenged neighborhoods into
those neighborhoods that have the kind
of social capital that your
neighborhoods have and that's i think
at the core of what people are asking
for it feels to me
because i'm familiar that you you do
want more community involvement
and and it sounds to me and it makes a
lot of sense that you
you're advocating a more nuanced
approach meaning
it's not just police you take care of
everything
it's trying to figure out what
situations
should we not be sending the police in
to handle but be sending someone else in
to handle is that correct
that's exactly right like any any gun
safety
instructor or any police officer would
tell you that
even if you're like a good guy with good
intentions just introducing a gun
introducing a firearm into a situation
inherently makes that situation
dangerous
right and so when people have a mental
health crisis
uh you know there's there's a number of
reasons people call 9-1-1 sometimes it's
because
i'm being robbed and i need an officer
to show up sometimes it's because i'm in
crisis sometimes it's because i just
need help with something
and we need to figure out how to bring
different levels of resource
uh to kind of meet those needs that's
something that we're doing i think very
well in saint paul
we have a chief conan who is constantly
focused on
what he calls making deposits in our
bank of trust with our community members
i hear them ask our officers after
anything happens three questions
were your actions reasonable uh were
they necessary and were they done with
respect and if you can answer yes to all
three of those questions
then you're probably gonna have a
relatively quick short conversation with
our chief
but if you can't answer yes uh to those
questions reasonable necessary and
respectful
uh then you're gonna have a longer
conversation with our chief we've
engaged
community members in the process of
defining what
public safety means for us uh and what
like what what those types of
investments are
uh and we we're actually already walking
down that road uh we have actually
already
launched a publix uh public health
mental health co-responder model
where we have uh social workers trained
in mental health
uh who are literally in the police car
riding along with police officers
uh to respond to some of those issues
that we know you know won't be solved by
just showing up and arresting somebody
that needs a long longer term approach
we're doing that work and we want to do
more of it
and i think it's important to see the
rest of the countries do some of that as
well
it's hard for me because of what you
said not to remember
that the reason flannel castile was
was was killed unnecessarily shockingly
killed
was that all he did was tell the officer
um i i i do have a weapon in the car and
i'm licensed to carry and he was saying
that
to create more safety and to be
responsible
tragically the officer said you're
holding a gun
uh uh don't bring out the gun and he
wasn't
and didn't uh but ended up getting shot
that bringing introducing police
and and people with weapons into every
situation
uh obviously can make that situation
instantaneously a thousand times more
dangerous
and volatile and uh so the idea that you
could have
different types of people responding in
different levels of need makes a lot of
sense
um i know that this leads into an
initiative called eight can't wait and
uh it has there's so much of it i i read
through
the eight can't wait uh uh program
and obviously there's things in there
that say well listen no more use of
chokeholds no more clamping down on uh
an airway or the carotid because
that is so dangerous and can go so wrong
so quickly
um but then there's so many other
initiatives in there that
once i read them made intuitive sense
which was about creating distance
um creating a bunch of parameters that
would
that would uh make the situation much
safer can you talk about some of those
initiatives from a can't wait yeah
without a doubt you know
the first thing you said caught in i
think brought together a number of the
things that we're talking about
in that you know fellaini could still
just being
himself and having a firearm even though
it was in his pocket and put away and
he's like
talking about it directly to let the
officer know that he that it was there
uh out of courtesy uh that uh just being
himself
was a threat that officer considered him
a threat just
sitting there being himself and and
therein lies i think a big part of the
problem is
if the the standard by which we
determine
whether somebody can be held accountable
for taking a life
is whether you feel threatened or not
and if my
very existence of my if my if my oxygen
makes you feel threatened well then it's
easy to see
why people all across this country say
wait a minute but we have to assert the
value of black lives
in a different way that's really
critical my father was a saint paul
police officer you mentioned that he's
served almost three decades
and i would see him just go through our
community solving problems
right and and identifying problems that
if you're not from our neighborhood you
probably wouldn't even know
was a problem you know in the first
place and so he was able to serve our
community in ways that
other officers just could not that
nobody else really could
because he's from here because he you
know grew up here he's raising his
children here he goes to the grocery
store he goes he's goes to church here
and he's like uh interwoven as a part of
the community
and so we have and and i always hear my
father say you know he goes
when you're that that much a part of the
community when when somebody's kids go
to school with your kids or
you grew up with their parents or you
know you're that interwoven together
uh instead of looking for justifiable
reasons
uh to use deadly force you can find an
unlimited number of reasons
not to use deadly force not to shoot
somebody not to kill somebody
so we've signed up for this uh a can
weight campaign
and it's about rewriting our use of
force policies
the truth is we did that when we first
came into office unfortunately
i think the saddest thing about george
floyd's murder is how historically
unsurprising it is
we've been on this road for quite some
time
and we are uh where we've gotten uh as a
result of kind of
where the road that we've been on and so
you know
this was a priority of mine when we
first came in office i think in the
first
two three months in office we had a
two-month
public engagement process to engage our
community in uh what our
use of force policies should be i don't
know of i just
i i don't know of any police department
any agency on the planet
before us frankly that has engaged
community members to say like
let's come up with an agreement what's
our compact on what
our use of force policies should be
around our
for for our police officers uh the final
policy that we passed two years ago
includes dozens uh i think a couple
dozen
of suggestions that we got straight from
community members and i think that's
really important
so the truth is with that eight can't
wait campaign most of those things are
things
that we actually already implemented two
years ago we wanted to make sure that
there was an explicit
uh you know that we explicitly addressed
uh some two
two of the items that the campaign kind
of identified as not specifically
addressed in our policy so
our chief did a fantastic job got that
turned around
i think within 24 hours of of realizing
that they had uh that they had
alerted us to this challenge uh but in
the end
uh our our policy which i think is is
very important it does a number of
things
it establishes uh that uh that duty to
de-escalate a situation
it establishes the duty to intervene
that we've all talked about and seen on
display
as necessary in the past week uh it
changes
from where we always talk about
reasonable force
it directs our officers to utilize
the minimum amount of force necessary
the minimal amount of force
both reasonable and necessary so not
just reasonable the question is
was it necessary in that situation and i
think pretty intriguingly it just
distinguishes between how officers
respond
uh to uh people who are being sort of
you know passively resistant right just
saying i'm not gonna get up when you say
get up versus people who are being
aggressive
toward an officer or toward another
human being the way we respond to them
has to be fundamentally different it
feels to me that there's there's a lot
of this sadly that is
um it's kind of common sense i mean
it is you and i are both human beings
i've been in the world
a lot longer than you but i know
just being on this planet that
when you treat someone like an
another you are going to get that same
feeling back
you get to know people when you talk to
them
when you ask them how you're doing and
you show any amount of empathy
you are creating a contract a social
contract
and these are things that we all know we
all know
but i think it's something in our wiring
we forget we can forget it or we can
drift away from it so
obviously when uh an officer
is being sent into a very a situation
where
for whatever reason he feels threatened
or or is tense or something
uh he might flip over there's that
circuit that flips over into this person
is the other
rather than treating it as uh
this is someone i may know someone from
my community who i've had experience
with because i've been
part of the community that's where
uh the notion that you've been talking
about to use
community policing more and i want to
use that word carefully
because obviously police officers have
to be
highly highly trained but
make sure that the community is involved
in keeping their community safe and that
they have
the some of the uh the power and
experience to do that
i i think there's no other way around
that my father wrote a book about
growing up uh and um i don't want to
spoil it for you
conan because i'm sure you're you've got
it on your list
but um i will have it on my list yeah i
will that's right
that's right there's a part of it where
he talks about when he was 25
and his two of his closest cousins and
like best friends in life
uh were murdered uh in a double homicide
and they were his closest friends they
had grown up together and somewhere
along the way they had taken a pact that
if somebody kills you i'll kill them
right
and it's kind of this situation where
the the whole neighborhood
uh you know assumes my father is going
to go after this guy
uh and he ends up getting acquitted for
the killing and disappears
right after it and you know my father
found out
years later probably decades later that
my grandfather had approached the
suspect's mother
and had paid for him to have a train
ticket or a bus ticket out of town
and that's an example i think of
community working together
right of community identifying a problem
community kind of stepping in and saying
this this this could go wrong in a way
that's that's that's bad for all of us
uh
and and and and let's work together to
create like community level solutions
so that's one of the things that we're
investing in as well and there's
there's a number of uh communities
around the country
uh who and around the world who are
having success with hiring community
members hiring neighbors
to as like interveners and interrupters
to identify
kind of these these kind of things that
could go really bad in community
and figure out how you know based on
community resources using community the
language of community
how to instruct and help prevent
violence from happening in the first
place
and i think that's that's that's the
core of what many of us are saying right
instead of this public safety strategy
instead of this kind of framework
and toolbox that all waits to start
until after a crime has been committed
right
how do we invest proactively in our
neighbors
how do we invest proactively in our you
know neighborhood areas
how do we invest proactively in our
families and our children
in such a way that makes people less
likely to have to act out in desperation
it's really uh it's preventative health
versus
versus chemotherapy and and i think
that's i think
uh what what i'm hoping this movement
uh this turmoil and this anguish and
this
activism leads to is a sense that
everybody knows you don't want to wait
to the stage where
you're getting chemotherapy you must
take care of yourself
and and we want to take care of our
community and the people in our
community that's right they all feel
invested
that's right and you know what what i
would say conan is
like right now we have the language for
it because as we know well
we're in like four different crises at
the same time right now we have the the
pandemic the
the physical health portion of it we
have the economic portion of the
pandemic
uh we have uh the the trauma uh the the
triggered historic trauma
of the video of george floyd's murder uh
and now we have
the the rebuilding that so many cities
around the country have to do
uh after all the destruction that's
happened in the last couple of weeks
and so we're we're facing all of these
things at the same time but one of the
things that the kobit 19 pandemic has
given us is a language around this right
we've got this pandemic and and conan
we've been talking about
violence as a public health you know
every time we see have a shooting or
every time we have an incident
somebody gets on tv and says this is a
public health crisis
and i agree with that but we haven't
really started to employ on any large
scale
public health solutions to it yet the
the pandemic has given us the language
of testing
so that we know who's impacted right so
that we know who's impacted by this
thing
uh that it's given us the language of
treatment so that once we identify who's
impacted we have to do
something to figure out how to intervene
and help them cure help them heal
from from this ailment and it's giving
us the language of contact tracing to
say
who who else might you have touched with
this right uh and the interest
interesting thing that you know a bunch
of epidemiologists and people smarter
than me have figured out
is that violence acts like
an epidemic violence does act like a
public health crisis in that
in the same ways you can predict the
case of the flu by having been around
someone with the case of the flu
the best predictor of a incident of
violence is a preceding incident of
violence
and so when we think about like
employing exactly what you just
described this public health
this public health lends to this it
creates a whole new
it opens a set of doors and a whole new
toolbox for us because
if we start identifying you know that
testing to say
who's been impacted by violence who's
who's most likely to be
uh to be touched by the ailments of
violence in our communities
uh to treat it and say how do we
intervene whether that's you know
the mental health uh whether that's you
know supportive resources
whether that's peer-to-peer counseling
how do we intervene to help kind of
break that cycle and who have they been
in touch with like how do we do the
contact tracing
to help to help uh identify isolate and
slow this pandemic
that to me seems to be the smartest
toolkit it's working in cities around
the country
that's what we're interested that's what
we're on the starting lines of
implementing here in saint paul
and that seems a lot more effective and
frankly a lot more research based
than just saying oh we don't feel safe
so we're going to put another
billions of dollars into police
prosecutors in prisons
this week and a half that we've just
experienced uh
doesn't just uh pass away
as so many things in our culture do we
have such a short attention span
and we tend to move from crisis to
crisis or whatever's trending
uh and and we don't want this
situation to be something that trended
for a couple of weeks
and then one way without there being
last lasting change are you optimistic
i would like to be optimistic that
because this
does feel different um i was too young
in 1968
to experience uh that upheaval
this does feel in my lifetime 57 years
it's the biggest thing that i've
witnessed and my hope is that it's
lasting do you feel this could be
lasting that
that if we keep doing the work and that
that people will stay focused and this
could lead us to a better place
i i am hopeful about that and i'll tell
you one of the amazing things that i've
learned is just to bet on the human
spirit
and that every time something just uh
horrifically ugly happens in community
we see
like this beautiful human spirit show up
and so in st paul
and in many of the other cities around
the country where we've seen
you know just massive heartbreaking
levels of destruction
uh and and and and kona i want to be
really clear
and i think you've spoken to this
already there there are sort of two
things
there were the protesters right and by
protesters i mean the people who
you know just are heartbroken by george
by george floyd's loss
i just feel it's it's it's it's unjust
uh and that he should still be alive
today
uh the people who feel like these four
officers must be held accountable in the
court
all four of them not just the one and
feel like we just have this like
soul-searching deep work to do as a
country uh to
to stop this cycle from happening over
and over again so so there's the
protesters
uh but then there's also like the
rioters the people who showed up
to break a window and to light a
building on fire
and to just create destruction and
community and so when i'm talking about
that kind of
that that that violence and destruction
that we saw those
those rioters uh who you know clearly
could not have been driven
by just a sense of a need for more
justice and fairness
while stripping our neighbors of their
ability to make a living
right or our senior citizens of their
ability to go to the corner
uh and get their life-saving medicine
from their pharmacy in the middle of a
pandemic
all i had to say is when the sun came up
the next morning
it came up on neighbors just coming out
of the woodworks
with shovels and brooms and bags and
trash cans we were sitting on our block
and all of a sudden some music came out
of nowhere and we looked up to say
where's that coming from and the army of
neighbors walked up the street
just cleaning up i mean it looked like a
scene from like the cat in the hat right
like just
neighbors coming out of the woodwork to
clean up and volunteering for each other
don't even know each other just
volunteering for each other we saw
we had a business we did a supply drive
last saturday
a business here whose windows are still
boarded up uh
who instead of cleaning up their own
business on saturday
open up their parking lot and we're
collecting
formula and diapers and canned foods and
families are coming to bring stuff and
families were coming to take stuff
and it was just this kind of massive
sense of community i did a
walk down the one of our main streets
that was impacted earlier this week
uh uh i'm sorry last week and uh
you know was was looking at businesses
who were boarded up and
passed two businesses that were boarded
up and somebody came out and said man
mayor mayor
and i said yes he said i just want you
to know from two to six pm today
uh we're feeding community members free
lunch and so if you know anybody who
needs food tell them to come by
and get their food here you know and
there are no shortages of those stories
where people are just taking care of
each other the business owner who's
house
who's building was literally burned to
the ground and she stopped me to say
my business was burned to the ground i
said i know and i'm really sorry we're
going to help you rebuild and she said
no that's not what i'm saying i'm saying
i have time to help right now i want to
help fundraise for other businesses
and i'll tell you that's the energy um
that that really touches me and when we
look at combining that energy with the
energy of kind of the young people and
the people all over our country who are
on the streets
i think we'll find that's the same
energy that created this country it's
the same energy that
ended slavery and that established civil
rights
and it's the same energy that i think is
going to carry us through to the next
chapter
on a slightly lighter note i want to
point out your mother is the chair
of the county board of commissioners yes
so
the way the government's set up and this
uh this really makes me smile for you to
get anything done
or approved as mayor and a very
influential mayor
you have to go to your mom well and
not exactly just because i'm sorry
conan when when i when i like get in
trouble and when i do stuff
that like people don't like they still
go and get my mom should we bring
into the conversation um so i have a
city council that i work with
and we are we are the county seat of
ramsey county
and so she is so we work very closely
with the county board
uh i don't uh i don't i don't go to them
to to request
a direct approval of my budget right
like that i go to our city council
but we have we we do work together very
closely
i'm actually really proud of the work
that she's done even in this space
uh she le she's led the process since i
think 2005 they started
of an initiative here called juvenile
detention alternatives initiative
uh we started off just saying look we're
locking up too many young people we had
at a time where we would go through our
juvenile detention centers
and it was so packed that there would be
cots in
in the hallways because it'd be beyond
capacity and they started investing
money
uh they started with a million dollar
investments into alternatives to
detention and just figuring out
can we create evening reporting centers
can we send you know
young people home on supervised reliefs
like what are all the different things
that we can do
instead of bringing young people into
the juvenile justice system it's so
important
because this is an incredible fact but
research shows
that uh the that that controlling for
other factors
a young person who has spent a night in
juvenile detention
is actually more likely to be an adult
offender like our system
is actually making them more likely to
be offenders in the future
not less likely that should be a gut
check moment for us
all that to say is uh they have uh
through through this juvenile detention
alternatives initiative
uh we have uh reduced uh average daily
intake
of young people in our community uh by i
think over 80 percent uh they have
shut down entire uh wings of that same
juvenile detention center
just last year we closed a place called
boys totem town which is like a secure
a secure confinement facility for young
people in our community and we've done
all of those things
coding without seeing any uh
corresponding
increase in juvenile crime in our
community and it goes to show
that uh we we've way over utilized
detention we've way over utilized
confinement and so
we're excited for the chance to work
together on kind of pushing this vision
forward
well i have to say uh you what an
impressive
family uh you come from your mom uh your
dad
uh obviously yourself um
you guys give me a lot of hope i know
that everybody has to do the work now i
had a conversation with w kamau bell
last week and we talked about it's about
the work and it's about doing the work
and that's not
just you that's not just people in the
black community it's everybody
especially especially everybody
everybody has to do the work but um
you give me a lot of hope uh you and and
your very
uh impressive family give me a lot of
hope
and well there's a lot of ways that i
probably
i i don't know what it's like to be you
but what i do know is i do know what
it's like to have a three-month-old
and you have my sympathy i appreciate it
i appreciate it she's she's she's great
you know kidding aside
she's fantastic 24 hours a day uh and i
appreciate your compliments of our
family i didn't get a chance to tell you
about my
sisters and my brother-in-laws and my
niece who just graduated from high
school and uh
and my wife who's a midwife uh whose
birthday it is today so oh happy
birthday
yeah thank you i appreciate that i'll
tell her you said so
i'm sure that'll mean the world to her
it will it absolutely will
so yeah we're surrounded by a group of
good folks and
you know between our our staff and the
city workers and you know the police and
firefighters who
just served our city with distinction
through this through these past couple
of weeks
i feel really blessed to be around uh
just a pretty incredible crew of folks
yeah well uh continued uh good luck to
you
in everything that you're doing and um
if
if things get too rough with the
three-month-old i'll say it again
you come stay at my place absolutely
absolutely if you could just text me the
directions
what you do is you talk you tell the
wife i've got some business i have to do
that's right i'll be gone uh i'll be
gone until she's about four years old
and then i'll come back right
right i'll just be a few months it'll
just be a few months i've got some
things yeah and then uh
hey thank you so much for taking the
time i really appreciate it
and i look forward to meeting you in
person sometime that would be very cool
absolutely i appreciate you having me on
and and i appreciate the way you're
using your platform
uh to uh to elevate other voices and
know stories that haven't necessarily
been told
but it's really powerful and it means a
lot well it means a lot to me
it's been it's selfishly i'm i'm
learning a lot and
uh and it's it's been a blessing and a
joy for me so thank you
very much uh mayor carter and continued
success to you
i appreciate it thanks for having me on
all right take care that was great
that was fantastic yeah yeah we're done
that was good that was awesome
that was long we did a lot so we'll see
what we can get
we're gonna have to compress some of it
for tbs but then all of it can go online
which is how 99
of people see it so nice nice yeah that
was terrific that was really terrific
that's pretty sweet i appreciate that
like i said i mean it's really enormous
for us i mean because these are
these are stories that people i mean
these are stories that my
great-grandparents were telling but
nobody was listening
and nobody was giving them a microphone
you know right and i mean
and so i appreciate you kind of opening
that up yeah i don't know it's what
uh this is how to get there i hope
wherever there
is so it'll never be perfect but i'm
hoping uh but we can do a lot better
than what yeah so yeah yeah we
definitely can
be well today all right i heard you were
planning on coming and doing a live
remote from st
paul like can i help you set that up if
we do a live remote from saint paul i'll
do it there hasn't been
we have because of covid no one's been
getting on a plane that's been the big
issue for us
right i'd love to come to saint paul if
we can figure it out
and uh a safe way to do it and uh and
it'd be nice to meet be nice to talk i'd
i'd love that too
when we open stuff back up um i i
there's other people on this call it's
it's being recorded so that's i think as
good as binding
a binding contract in some countries and
so uh you'd be shocked at how slippery i
am you know
i am a slippery
right you can you know i say anything
and then uh
you know i just disappear for years at a
time uh
no i really would it would be an honor
to meet you and uh and to grab a meal
and then
if we can figure out you know uh a good
piece to do
with it that would be fantastic all
right that'd be ama i i'd definitely be
down for that so i appreciate it
when when you're ready i'm ready all
right if you can handle me in person
it's a lot to take in
i'm i'm told i am as well so
we'll see what happens i'm told i
resemble a very tall belgian woman
so just be ready for that i have never
been told that hey thank you so much
take care all right thanks a lot have a
great rest of the day you too
all right